with more than two million refugees
forced to flee ukraine many displaced
children and families need help with
vital supplies and while there are a
slew of traditional ways to give like
through the international rescue
committee or global giving ukraine
crisis relief fund here are some other
unique approaches to giving
one way people are helping ukrainians is
by sending money directly through airbnb
sixty one thousand nights were booked at
the beginning of the month that's nearly
two million dollars in bookings airbnb
has temporarily waived booking fees so
it won't profit from this the airbnb
effort so interesting started online
really was like almost a crowdsourcing
great idea cbs news business analyst
jill schlesinger says other companies
including uber and etsy have also come
up with novel ways to help uber has
basically said we're going to give free
rides to people who are at the ukrainian
polish border and uber users here in the
us can give through the app etsy said no
fees for people who are selling stuff
who are based in the ukraine some people
are turning to cryptocurrency to send
money but beware of scams according to
bitdefender labs crypto scams targeting
ukrainian relief efforts are
intensifying if you've got an
organization make sure it's legit the
ftc sent out tips on how to donate
including checking out the organization
online search for words like review scam
or complaint before you send any money